Tucker has been releasing some
interesting information from these 40
000 Plus hours here he is showing that
the police basically acted as tour
guides for several of the January 6th
people who got into the capitol but
particularly the shaman remember the
shaman with the crazy hat and the face
makeup and the whole thing watch this
this is wild dangerous conspiracy
theorist dressed in outlandish costume
who led the violent Insurrection to
overthrow American democracy for these
crimes chansley was sentenced to nearly
four years in prison far more time than
many violent criminals now receive what
did Jacob chansley do to receive this
punishment to this day there is dispute
over how chansley got into the Capitol
building but according to our review of
the internal surveillance video it is
very clear what happened once he got
inside virtually every moment of his
time inside the capital was caught on
tape the tape show that Capitol Police
never stopped Jacob chansley they helped
him they acted as his tour guides here's
video of chansley in the Senate chamber
Capitol police officers take him to
multiple entrances and even try to open
locked doors for him we counted at least
nine officers who were within touching
distance of unarmed Jacob chansley not
one of them even tried to slow him down
chancelly understood that Capitol Police
were his allies video shows him giving
thanks for them in a prayer on the floor
of the Senate watch
ing
to these police officers to allow us in
this building contrast the reality of
what Jacob chansley did in the Capitol
building on January 6th okay so you
really gotta understand this guy is now
in jail for four years I have no doubt
he's been been treated unbelievably
horribly he's not the only one in jail
obviously but officers are literally
escorting him looking for doors to open
I mean when you see that moment where
the guy turns the doorknob and then they
see that that door's locked they
unlocked other doors from they they
escorted him into the chamber right why
didn't when those nine cops and he just
walks by him why didn't anyone be like
oh sir you can't uh walk in here oh you
can't do that sir we're not going to do
that we do love the hat but you can't
come in here but they don't do any of
that because this was all I don't know
that it was an inside job exactly but
who was giving them the orders to stand
out why were so many barricades pulled
away and doors opened for these people
do you really think as AOC and Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi have stated
that that guy was a dangerous
insurrectionist and that the United
States government was in danger of
falling within a couple hours nobody had
plans nobody had weapons uh for the most
part they didn't even vandalize the
freaking place I think somebody might
have taken Nancy Pelosi's keyboard okay
you can't steal things anyway here is
Tucker debunking this idea that Brian
sicknick who is the police officer
supposedly killed by January Sixers uh
that it was much more nefarious that
that's the idea that it was much more at
Affairs than it actually turned out to
be take a look at this to this day media
accounts describe sicknick as someone
who was quote slain on January 6th the
video we reviewed proves that is a lie
here is surveillance footage of sicknick
walking in the capital after he was
supposedly murdered by the mob outside
by all appearances sicknic is healthy
and vigorous he's wearing a helmet so
it's hard to imagine he was killed by a
head injury
whatever happened to Brian sicknick was
very obviously not the result of
violence he suffered at the entrance to
the capital
doesn't answer every question from
January 6th far from it but it does
prove Beyond doubt that Democrats in
Congress assisted by Adam kinzinger and
Liz Cheney lied about what happened that
day they are liars that is conclusive
and that fact should prevent them from
ever being taken seriously again
[Music]
thank you